[Musik]
es beginnt heute so viel zu wenig
nachlassen wie die auf suche nach dem 25
1 punkten irgendwo solches 7
[Musik]
ich bin 25 er kann weitergehen
sie kaufen ist hat es genießen
danach geht es zum beispiel so gut das
ist die c-130 des österreichischen
bundesheeres und das hier das ist der
blick aber ist borowski in langen leben
und gestolpert
was macht sie genau wie sie gab es 25
ist das einzige bataillonen in
österreichischen bundesheeres zur gänze
aus berufssoldaten und büros land
besteht und hier sind für einsätze im
ausland sowohl aber aus dem inland
vorgesehen das heißt wir werden nur für
einsätze bereitgehalten
noch dazu sind wir in luft wanderverband
das heißt wir keinen ersatz verbracht
werden wir damit flächen flugzeugen sind
mir die 230 oder mit hubschraubern in
deutschland unsere hausaufgaben zu
erfüllen
aufsteigend um entweder mit dem
fallschirm aus der luft oder irland mit
den hochschulen also ist das ist
natürlich bei militärischen verband
immer ein top thema da haben wir gleich
zwei dinge die religion der stg hat zwei
kommandos ist aber auch immer ein
glasklares starker verriegelung wo die
beladung von unten erfolgt mittels eines
magazin des weges 30 schuss fast genauso
weit dass wir noch das band habe rohr
das thema leuchtmunition dann wandte
aber munition und sprechen munition
verschießen kann
es gibt wahnsinnig viele
hochinteressante jobs beim bundesheer
und auch bei eur 1 hat glaube ich wäre
sogar noch platz haben derzeit 450
personen bei uns und könnten auf 550 bis
560 anwachsen von sich glaubt dass er
das zeug zur falschen mega arena zum
falschen liga hat kann sie ihre zeit das
sagen und es gibt unterschiedliche jobs
wir haben gern mal der bereich holz
plätze frei im sanitätsbereich
arbeitsplätze von infanterie kompanien
einer kampf unterstützungskampagne wo
wir bei der lenkwaffen sowie faire
scharfschützen
der eindruck ist wie viele leute können
damit 40 und die springen daraus
gesprächen darum schaue ich mir dann von
hier aus abend werdet sicher großartig
aus durch die möglichkeit auch von innen
das zu machen denn ja da rein bahrain
mit euch mit uns kein problem
[Musik]
allerdings wünschte glück gehabt und gut
land und das ist sie auch
wie gehabt sind helm auf einfach raus im
unterjährigen was mich betrifft
zumindest einmal allerdings das erste
wir sehen uns wieder in allen steckt das
wird richtig interessant
[Musik]
alle gut gelernt wir sind mittlerweile
wieder ein einsteig da gibt es einiges
zu sehen
aber das ist das neue schutz
transportfahrzeug des österreichischen
bundesheers eines der modernsten geräte
kann ohne 12,7 mm wird von ihnen
gesteuert hatte auch eines mit namen wie
einfach es muss ja dann setze ich meinen
pass uhr und jetzt was ich damit
[Musik]
das ist ein schweres jahr 12,7 mm mit
dem bekämpfen mehr material ziele bis zu
einer entfernung von 1800 meter die
schwerste waffe batterie und ab hier
helmpflicht 120 millimeter granatwerfer
höchstens 7500 15 meter
damit das gerät schießen kann braucht
man beobachte er sitzt nur auf der bank
mächtig 6 170 kilo
[Musik]
die letzte waffe des heutigen tages sein
swing quartet 2008 startete mit einem
draht gelenkt optisch gesteuert ist ziel
und gepolsterte zähler kampfpanzer oder
ähnliches zu bekämpfen bis 2200 meter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das habe ich hier auch noch eine
spezielle weste bekommen und dann
speziellen helm jetzt gibt's zu heißer
kampf
[Musik]
es ist entertainer feuer anforderungen
sofort oben
es war ein spektakulärer verkaufen was
unten ankommen
der häuserkampf die übung größte teil
der infanteriekompanie benutzen wir ja
modernsten mitteln für den einsatz aus
zufügen
sie haben die echtzeit auswertung und
die simulationsanlage die arme hinten
sehen wir bereits die bewegten bilder
das sind wir im angriff jetzt auch diese
kreuzkamp anlage
man sieht bei jeder einzelnen soldaten
geben soldaten wo er sich gerade
befindet wie erfährt wie sich die gruppe
bewegt und kann dann in der analyse ganz
genau schauen wo kann man sich
verbessern das ist professionell
unglaubliches praktikum an fantastischen
interessanten und fordernden berufen
die dann aber alle ineinander greifen zu
einer extrem hohes rating und tolle
mannschaft und hat sich heute sehr gut
geschlagen gibt auch der meinung dass
eine einreise
[Musik]
[Applaus]